au cinéma les yeux d'elsa
cette semaine nous vous proposons une
soirée spéciale john carpenter la c1
méfie cinéaste favoris donc forcément
j'en fais beaucoup mais c'est surtout
parce que il ya beaucoup de ces films
qui ressorte ces derniers temps et puis
parce que c'est un cinéaste important
des années 80 aux états unis mais qui a
influencé le cinéma mondial
alors on avait passé the thing on a
passé les aventures de jack burton dans
les griffes du mandarin et puis là on va
vous faire une soirée trois films de
john carpenter puisqu'il y en a quatre
qui ressorte qui sont ressorties cette
année le 1er juin ce sera invasion los
angeles
alors c'est un film qui est étrangement
intéressant aujourd'hui puisque en fait
c'est un film qui parle de le monde dans
lequel on vit maîtrisé par des
extraterrestres qui seraient cachées etc
mais quand on met des lunettes de soleil
spéciales on arrive à les voir et à voir
que toutes les publicités sont des
messages incitatifs à obéir sans dormir
regarder la télé etc etc
le deuxième film qu'on va vous proposer
ses seins mais petit chouchou c'est un
des plus connus c'est le film qui a fait
que john carpenter est un peu arrivé au
sommet c'est donc encore et toujours
avec snake plissken new york 1997 grand
grand film dans un futur improbable new
york manhattan est devenu
une prison et donc on
on retrouve notre héros qui doit sauver
le président tombé dans cette prison et
puis le dernier the fog est le seul vrai
film d'horreur de la soirée qui interdit
aux moins de 12 et qui donc sera
présenté en fin de soirée
je me ferai un plaisir de vous
accueillir de vous présenter tous ses
films et de vous dire tout ce que je
sais sur ce cinéaste et je vous promets
qu'on passera une très très bonne soirée
tous ensemble donc à vendredi 19 avril
dès 19h30 au cinéma les yeux d'elsa
[Musique]